- Now this my friends, is what we used,
phew, the old, old times.
What's up, peeps?
(upbeat music)
- So, I think these are for the cameras,
and you put these in front of the cameras,
and you do it like this.
(upbeat music)
- Interesting.
- Does this, like, hold discs?
- Tiles?
(upbeat music)
(beep)
- What?
- It's like this walkie talkie.
The old walkie talkie.
(beep)
What's up, guy?
These walkie talkies are for detectives.
- Oh, this maybe was used for the army?
(beep)
- It's like an alarm.
- It's easier to use than a cell phone,
'cause then you have your contacts.
You can just press your contact button
and then you just call your friend.
(upbeat music)
- I figured that this would go into here.
- How do you think these get in?
- You put it inside and then you can,
like, in the morning you can hear news.
- This is something you definitely use
to watch something.
- Oh, I can explore inside of it.
- How do you get the tape out?
Oh, there it is.
- That's complicated.
I just press a button and boom.
(playful music)
- This is a phone, you
use this to call people.
This is, like, a really old one.
- Hello?
- In the back old days
you used to put it up
to your ear and you
have to use, like, this
to get the number.
- What if it's an emergency?
Like, what if someone's robbing your house
and you do, like, nine.
Nope, nope, wrong.
And if you mess up.
What do you do if you mess up?
- I feel so mad for Madonna.
She's old.
Madonna has to use this type of phone.
Sorry Madonna.
I don't know if you're still alive but--
(laughing)
(upbeat music)
- And this is a walkie talkie.
Oh, it's a cell phone.
- I think they would call it a flip phone,
because you, like, flip it
and then once you have to close it.
It's like that.
- Cops use it,
"Hey, 43, call 43, got
criminals on 92nd street.
"Go, go, go."
And criminals can use this too.
"Hey, I just robbed a bank.
"How we doing?
"Got stacks of money."
- Press two once to do a,
press two twice to do b.
- That would take forever and ever
and ever and ever.
- This is, like, what old people use to,
"Hi, honey."
Yeah, I prefer iPhones,
but these were cool.
If it's all you have I understand.
(electronic music)
- This looks fun.
Tamagotchi.
- Tam-tam.
- Tamagotchi.
Tamagotchi.
- Yay, my Tamagotchi arrived.
- I know what these are!
They're called tamagotchis!
- That's just boring.
You just press buttons.
That's all you do.
- I'm so glad I was born 2005, modernized.
I don't want to be born in the 1980s.
I feel bad for my teachers and my parents.
(electronic music)